Herkese selamlar sevgili 9. sınıflar.
Nasılsınız bakalım? Umarım keyifler
yerinde, her şey yolunda gidiyordur.
Evet ve ufaktan yazılılar geliyor.
Biliyorum içimiz biraz buruk ama yapacak
bir şey yok. Bizim burada tabii ki de
görevimiz seni yazılılara çok iyi bir
şekilde hazırlamak. Bugün de neredeyiz?
8. dersimiz. Gerçek sayıların işlem
özelliklerini mor Tosuncuk'tan
kaldığımız yerden devam ettireceğiz.
Şimdi yazılıda demişken biliyorsun
kitapta biraz şöyle gördüğün gibi
tuğladan hallice e senin için yazılı
kısımlarını da düşündük. Biliyorsun
burada beraber derslerimizi işliyoruz.
Yani bir akıllı defter formatı gibi
düşünebilirsin. Burada birlikte önce
dersimizi öğreniyoruz, anlıyoruz. Ondan
sonra da sana ödev testleri veriyordum
biliyorsun. Ve artık yazılı kısımlarına
da şimdiden ödevini verebilirim. En
baştan başla. Bak şöyle her dersimizin
sonunda ne var? Şu gri sayfalar. Gri üst
tarafı görüyorsun. Bunlar o konu sonunda
o konuyla alakalı yazılı da çıkabilecek
soru tarzlarıdır. Bak bir tane genel bir
yazılı örneği koymadık. Her dersin
sonuna yazılı çalışması koyduk. Yani her
derste o dersle alakalı karşına gelme
ihtimali %99 olan soru tarzlarını
yerleştirdik. Dolayısıyla da yazılı
öncesinde şimdiden bence başla. En
baştan şöyle tüm yazılı sayfalarını
tekrar tekrar çöz. Yani oralarda neler
var? Daha çok böyle yazılıda çıkabilecek
tarz açık uçlu sorular var. Eee, yeni
maarif modele uygun sorular var.
Dolayısıyla da çok faydalı olacaktır.
Eee, çok da güzel dönüşler, geri
dönüpler de alıyoruz. Bunu sen de zaten
trend yol heps burada gibi sayfalardaki
yorumlardan da inceleyebilirsin.
Gerçekten eğer hala edinmediysen de
söyleyeyim. Açıklamada linkleri var.
Oradan da inceleyebilirsin. Eee, diyorum
ve biz ufaktan o zaman ne yapalım?
İşimize geri dönelim. Yani 8. dersimiz
gerçek sayıların işlem özelliklerine
başlıyoruz şimdi. Evet aslında nispeten
kolay bir ders olacak. Eee çünkü yani
çok da eee zor bir konu başlığı değil
açıkça söylemek gerekirse en azından 8.
ders için söylüyorum. 9. derste bu konu
başlığından devam ediyoruz. Oralarda
biraz işler çirkinleşebilir. Şimdiden
ben uyarım yapayım. Sonra Meli hoca
söylemediydi falan olmasın. Hadi
başlayalım. Şimdi öncelikle bir bilgiyle
aslında bir tanımla başlayacağız. O da
nedir? Kesin ve doğru. Yani kesin doğru.
Özür dilerim. Kesin ve doğru olur mu?
Kesin doğru ya da kesin yanlış bir hüküm
bildiren gençler biz ifadelere önerme
diyoruz. Tamam mı? Bak burada doğru ya
da yanlış demiyorum. Kesinlikle doğru
olacak veya kesinlikle yanlış olacak.
Yanlış da olabilir. Tamam mı? Kesinlikle
yanlış da diyebilirsin. İşte biz bunlara
matematikte önerme diyoruz. önermeler
sözel veya sembolik dille de ifade ifade
edilebilir. Şimdi işte biz bunu
göreceğiz. Yani sözel dil ve eee
sembolik diliğiz. Bunlarla alakalı
örneklerde çözeceğiz. Şimdi ilk sorumuza
bakalım. Aşağıda verilen matematiksel
ifadelerin doğru veya yanlış olma
durumlarını belirleyip uygun olana tik
atacağız. Şimdi yani doğruluk ve
yanlışlığına da bakacağız. Ondan sonra
da işte doğru mu yanlış mı
işaretleyeceğiz. Ama bazı ifadeler doğru
ya da yanlış belirtmeye debilebilir.
Böyle muallakta da kalabilir. Özellikle
de soru cümleleri. Dolayısıyla onlar bir
önerme değildir. Bakın önerme olabilmesi
için benim ağzımdan çıkan bir cümlenin
önerme olabilmesi için kesin doğru ya da
kesin yanlış olması lazım. Örnek doğal
sayılar 0dan başlar. Bu bir önermedir
değil mi? Ben kesin net bir şey söyledim
şu an sana. Doğal sayılar 0'dan başlar.
Net bir şey söyledim. Doğru mu? Doğru.
Tamam. Bu o zaman doğru bir önerme.
Doğal sayılar 1'den başlar dedim. Hoppa.
Ne oldu şu an? Ben sana yanlış bir
önerme verdim ama önerme mi? Önerme.
Neden önerme? Yanlış hocam. Yanlış bir
şey söylüyorsun sen. Olsun. Sonuçta net
bir şey, kesin bir şey söyledin mi?
Evet. Hatta kesinlikle yanlış bir şey
söyledim. Değil mi? Evet. O zaman bunun
adına biz önerme diyeceğiz. Tamam. Mevzu
bu. Hadi gel şimdi örneklerimizi
inceleyelim.
Dereceleri eşit olan köklü sayılar
çarpılırken
aynı dereceden kök açılıp sayılar
çarpılıp kökün içine yazılır. Doğru mu
yanlış mı? Bir kere bu net bir önerme
değil mi? Çünkü kesin bir hüküm
içeriyor. Eee bu cümleye ben tabii ki de
ne diyeceğim? Doğru diyeceğim. Çünkü
dereceleri eşitliyor. Mesela 3.
dereceden √5 eee ile 3. dereceden √7
diyelim. Mesela bunları çarparken nasıl
çarpıyorduk? Zaten çarpma bizim
istediğimiz eee hazır bulunuşluklardan
biriydi. Derecelerin eşit olmasını şart
koşuyorduk. Değilse dereceleri
eşitliyorduk. E burada aynı dereceden
kök açılıp içerideki sayıları çarpıp
içeriye yazıyorduk. Değil mi? Mevzu bu.
O zaman bu ifadeye ben doğru diyeceğim.
Diğerine geçelim. Şimdi diyor ki iki
tane tam sayının karesi kendisine
eşittir sadece. Yani karesi kendisine
eşit olan iki tane tam sayı vardır
diyor. Öyle mi? Bakalım. Şimdi bir kere
0ın karesi var. Kendisi yine 0a eşit.
Yani kendisine eşit. 0 tam sayı mı?
Evet. Bir de ne var? 1in karesi var. E o
da yine neye eşit? 1'e eşit. Bak mesela
-1in karesi desem ben sana kendisine
eşit diyemezsin. Çünkü o + 1'e eşit.
İşte burada sadece iki tane tam sayı
örneği bulabildik. O zaman bu bir
önermedir bu arada hani zaten onu
atlıyorum. Hiç konuşmadık bile. Çünkü
kesin bir hüküm belirtmiş. İki tane tam
sayının karesi kendisine eşittir. Çok
net konuşmuş. Bu bir önerme ve doğru bir
önerme. Çünkü 0 ve 1'in dışında başka
kendisine karesi kendisine eşit olan
sayı yok. Tamam geçtim. Karesi 25 olan 3
tane tam sayı değeri vardır diyor. Bu
bir önerme. Net söylemiş. Vardır. Kesin
konuşuyor. Lan sen ne haddin? Öyle bir
şey var mı? Yok. Önerme. Evet. Doğru.
Evet. Önerme olduğu kısmı doğru ama
içerik yanlış. Karesi 25 olan iki tane
sayı var. -5 ya da 5. Dolayısıyla ben
buna ne diyorum? Sen yanlışsın. Yanlış
kal diyoruz. Tamam mı? Peki şimdi
sonuncuya geldim. 2 üzeri x + 1 8
olduğuna göre x kaçtır? Ne bileyim ben?
Yani sen şu an bana bir önerme mi
sundun? Hayır. Bu arkadaş bir önerme
zaten değildir. Dolayısıyla doğru ya da
yanlış olduğu da belirlenemez. Tamam.
Çünkü bu bir soru cümlesi. Yani soru
cümleleri önerme olamazlar. Kesin bir
doğruluk ya da kesin bir yanlışlık
istiyorum. Burada sen bana eksi
soruyorsun. X2'dir. Ne yapayım? Şu an
mevzumuz o değil ki. Anlaştık mı? Bak bu
mesela bir önerme değil. Dolayısıyla
doğru ya da yanlışlığını belirleyemem.
Peki
şimdi aşağıda sözel olarak verilen
ifadeleri uygun semboller yardımıyla
yazacağız. Tamam. Şimdi şöyle bir 2inci
sorumuza gelelim. Şöyle bir biraz daha
yakınlaşsam nasıl olur? Hcuk 2'yi
görmesek de olur değil mi? Tabanları
eşit olan üslü ifadeler çarpılırken
üsler toplanır. Ortak tabanın üssü
olarak yazılır demişiz. Bu nedir? Bu
sözel olarak verilen bir ifadedir. Biz
bunu ne yapacağız? Semboller yardımıyla
ifade edeceğiz. Yani hep aslında o e
tanım kısımlarını atlıyoruz ya.
atlıyorsunuz daha doğrusu. Hemen örneğe
geçesimiz var. Örnekte daha iyi
anlıyoruz çünkü. İşte aslında o tanım
kısımlarında verilenler
matematiksel sembollerle size konu
anlatmadır. Mesela nedir? Tabanları
eşit. Ne alabilirim ben? Tabanları eşit
a diyebilirim. Yani sayımın tabanı a
olsun. Hani hep öyle genelleme yapıyoruz
ya. Burada da onu yapacağız. A üzeri x
diyeceğim. Bir tane daha üstlü ifade
yapayım. Çünkü çarpma yapacağız ya. Onun
da tabanı a olacak. Ona da y diyeceğim.
Bunu işte ne nasıl göstereceğim? Üstler
toplanır. Ortak tabanın üstüne
yazılırmış ya. A üzeri x + y olarak
göstereceğiz. Yani çok basit bir aslında
tanım. Daha doğrusu sözel bir ifade.
İşte matematikçeye çevirirken sayı
kullanmayacağız. Tamam mı? Yani burada
ifadeyi genelleyeceğiz. Sen artık burada
a yerine 2 yaz, 5 yaz, 7 yaz, fark
etmez. İkincide ne demişiz? Bir sayının
karesi 0 ya da 0'dan büyüktür. Sayımız
ne olsun? Genelde bilinmeyen bir şey
sallayın. X diyebilirsiniz. Yani
cebirsel olarak yazacağız. X'i yazdım.
Karesi diyor. O zaman x kareden
bahsediyoruz. Ne olacakmış? 0 ya da
0'dan büyük. Bu bir eşitsizlik aslında
değil mi? Dolayısıyla x² büyük ya da
eşit diyeceğim 0'dan. Ne oldu? Ben sözel
ifadeyi matematikçeye çevirdim. Yani
Türkçeci bunu bu şekilde okur.
Matematikçi bu şekilde okur gibi de
düşünebilirsin. Yani ben sana sadece şu
ifadeyi verirsem şunu verdim. x k> eş 0
dedim. Sen buradan hemen ne anlıyorsun?
He bir sayının karesi 0a eşit ya da
büyük olabiliyormuş. Matematikçeyi şunu
Türkçeye çevirme mevzumuz bu. Tamam. Ya
da matematikçeden Türkçeye çevireceğiz.
Yani translate. Dersimiz translate.
Şimdi sayı kümelerinin işlem
özelliklerine gelelim. İlk özelliğimiz
nedir? Değişme özelliği. Şimdi değişme
nerede var? Toplamada var. Toplama
işleminde değişme özelliğini nasıl
söyleyebiliriz? Doğal sayı, tam sayı,
rasyoneller ya da gerçek sayılar
kümesinde toplamaya göre değişme
özelliği vardır. Değişme özelliğini
sembolik olarak nasıl gösteririz? Çok
basit. X + Y = Y + X deriz. Tamam mı?
Yani bunu ben sana verdiğimde yani
öğretmenin sana şunu verdi. x + Y = Y +
X yazdı. Yukarıda verilen matematiksel
ifadeyi sözel olarak yazınız. Burada ne
anlatılmak isteniyor? Hani yeni marif
modeldeyiz ya artık. Mevzularımız bu
şekilde. Burada anlatılmak istenen şu. X
+ Y + bak toplama işlemi e= Y + X
yazılmış. An burada diyeceksin ki o
zaman
eee
doğal sayı, tam sayı, rasyonel sayı ve
gerçek sayılar kümesinde toplama
işlemine göre değişme özelliği vardır
diyeceksin. Yani burada anlatılmaya
çalışılan mevzu değişme özelliği.
Toplama işleminde değişme özelliği.
Tamam. Mevzu bu kadar. Örnekler üstünden
gidelim. Aşağıda verilen toplama
işlemlerin sonuçlarını bulunuz. Burada 4
+ 9 bak nedir? 13'tür. 9 + 4 de 13'tür.
Yani değişme özelliği yani sayıların
yeri değişmiş ama bak ne oldu? Sonucumuz
değişmedi. Ya da diğerinde burada da ne
yapabiliriz? Payda eşitleyerek hemen
işlemimizi yaparız. 3 kere 3 nedir? 9. 5
x 2 10. Toplarsam üst taraf 19. Alt
tarafta da 3 x 5 15.
19/15. Sen bunun yerlerini
değiştirdiğinde cevap değişecek mi?
Hayır. Aynen kalacak. Yani değişme
özelliğine örnek veriniz dedi. Bunlardan
faydalanabilirsin. Ya da yok ben şov
yapacağım. Gerçek sayılardan örnek
vereceğim. Yani daha doğrusu
kareköklülerden biraz ağır bir örnek
vereceğiz dedik. Tamam. -3√2 + 2√2
nedir? -1 tane √2'dir. Değil mi? Sen
burada sayıların yerini değiştirince
sonuç değişir mi? değişmez. Peki bu
değişme özelliği kardeşimiz çarpma
işleminde de var. Doğal sayı, tam sayı,
rasyonel ve gerçek sayılarda yine çarpma
işlemine göre değişme özelliği vardır.
Aynısının bir başka versiyonunu
anlatıyoruz. Az önce toplamayı anlattık.
Şimdi de çarpma. Çarpmayı da x y = y x
olarak ifade edebiliriz. Hemen bunun da
sayısal örneklerini hızlıca geçelim. 4
kere -7 nedir? Artı ile eksinin çarpımı
- 4 x 7 28 yer değiştirdiğinde bir şey
değişir mi? Değişmez. Cevap yine -28.
Burada ne var? 3/10 var. Yer
değiştirirsen yine 3/10. Burada ne var?
2 x 3 6 5 x 2 10 6√10 var. Sayıların
yerleri değiştiğinde cevap değişmez.
Çünkü değişme özelliği var. Mesela
öğretmenin şu örneği yazıp tamam mı?
Burada ne anlatılmak isteniyordur?
Burada mı? hangi matematiksel tanıma
örnek verilmiştir şeklinde bir soru
sorabilir. Ne diyorsun? Burada çarpma
işleminin değişme özelliğine örnek
verilmiştir diyoruz. Çünkü sayıların
yeri değişmesine rağmen sonuç değişmiyor
diye de altına açıklama yapabilirsin.
Şimdi gençler doğal sayı, tam sayı,
rasyonel ve gerçek sayılar kümesinde
dikkat dikkat çıkarma ve bölme
işlemlerine göre değişme özelliği
yoktur. Yani çıkarma işleminde değişme
yapamazsın. 2'den 3 çıkartmakla 3'ten 2
çıkartmak aynı şey değil. Tamam. Bölme
için de öyle. 2'yi 3'e böleceksin. 3'ü
2'ye böleceksin. Oğlum bunlar sonucu
farklı. O yüzden mevzu bu şekilde.
Gelelim ikinci özelliğimiz birleşmeye.
Şimdi neyden bahsettik önce? Değişme.
Toplamada çarpma da vardı. Birleşme
bakalım nerelerde var. Öncelikle
toplamada var. Doğal sayı, tam sayı,
rasyonel gerçeklerde toplama işlemine
göre birleşme özelliği vardır.
Birleşmenin sembolik olarak tanımı
nedir? A + B + C, A + B + Clinde
gösterilebilir. Birleşme neydi? En az 3
tane arkadaşımız olacak karşımızda. Bu
üçlüden haliyle biri dışarıda şu an.
İçerideki herhangi biriyle
birleştirebiliriz, yanbiliriz. kavuşma
özelliği gibi de düşünebilirsin. Burada
bak ne yapmışız? A la B'yi topladık.
C'yi dışladık. Tamam. Burada ne yaptım
ben? Birleşme özelliğini gösterdim
toplamada. Hemen sayısal örneğimize
bakalım. Şimdi aşağıda verilen toplam
işlemin sonuçlarını bulunuz. Ne var?
Hemen baktım. 4 + 5 + 9 e 5 + 9 aslında
14 değil mi? Evet. E buradan cevap
nedir? 18. Alttaki işleme bakıyorum.
Önce parantez içi yapılıyor ya hani 9 e
bir de dışarıda 9 var. 9 yine nedir? 18.
Bak sayılar
bir başka eşlenmeye rağmen yani bir sayı
diğer bir sayıyla birleşmesine rağmen
sonuç değişmedi. O zaman diğeri 4 2 3 5
toplanıyor. Buradan ne gelecek bana?
7,7.
E dışarıda kim vardı? 5,4. Ben bunları
toplarsam ne olacak? 13,1 mi? Yani
sonuçlar çok da önemli değil de sen
artık o işlemleri yaparsın. Tamam mı?
Meli hocanız yaşlı. Bazen atlayabiliyor.
Gözler kesmiyor bizim. Şuradan şurayı
göremiyorum. Şimdi hep gözler o yüzden
kısık. Ondan sonra ne var? 4.2'yi 4,2'yi
dışarıya sallamışız. 3,5'la 54
birleşmiş. E buradan bana ne gelecek?
8,9 değil mi? Şimdi dışarıda 4,2 8,9'ile
toplanırsa bana buradan ne gelecek? Yine
13,1
gelecek değil mi? 2 9 daha 11 elde var 1
12 13 Tamam. Hatta böyle bir sağlama da
yapmış olduk aslında. İşte mevzu bu.
Sana öğretmenin diyecek ki yine şöyle
bir eee örnek verip burada yazar ne
anlatmak istiyor diye soracak. Tamam.
Çarpma işleminde de birleşme özelliğimiz
var. Aynı az önceki tanımın eee
toplamasını çıkar kelime olarak yerine
çarpmayı yaz. Tamam. Burada da yine ne
diyoruz? Doğal sayı, tam sayı, rasyonel
gerçeklerde çarpmaya göre birleşme
özelliği vardır. Aynı şekilde dediğim
gibi toplamayı çıkar, çarpma koy yerine.
Hemen bunun da sayısal örneklerine
bakalım. Çarpma işlemimiz sonuçlarını
bulalım. Şimdi içeride ne var? Öncelikle
2 x 3 6 5 x 4 20 var. 1/3 ile çarparsam
1 x 6 3 x 20 60 istersen bunu
sadeleştirip 1/10 diye de yazabilirsin.
Alt tarafta önce parantez içi ne
gelecek? 2/15 dışarıda 3/4 dışarıya
atmışız onu. 2 x 3 6 15 ile 4'ü çarptım
60 yine aynı cevabı aldım. Yan tarafa
bakıyorum yine bir çarpma işlemi var
burada da köksüzler 12 köklüler çivi
çiviyi söktü 2 kaldı. 12 2 dışarıda da
√2 var. 24 x √2 burada 4√2 ile √2'yi
eşlemişiz birleştirmişiz.
Buradan bana 4, buradan da 2. 4 kere 2 8
geldi. 3√2 ile 8'i çarparsam yine cevap
24√2 olacaktır. Haydi devam. Şimdi yutan
elemandan bahsediyoruz. Yutan eleman
çarpma işleminde olur ve çarpmada yutan
0dır. Tamam. Yani bir sayı 0'la
çarpılırsa biliyorsun cevap 0 olur.
Toplama, çıkarma ve bölme işlemlerinde
yutan eleman yoktur. Hemen işlem noktalı
yerlere gelmesi gereken. Yani burada 5
kere 0 işte 7,5'ile neyi çarparsam 0.
Burada da 0ı yazdım. Geçtim. Gelelim
çarpmadaki dağılma özelliğine. Bu da
yine sayıda e sayı kümelerinin
özelliklerinde var. Çarpmanın toplama ve
çıkarmaya dağılma özelliğini sembolik
olarak nasıl gösteriyoruz? Şu ikisiyle.
Yani ne yapıyorduk? A'yı hem birinci ile
hem de ikinci ile çarpıp ayrı ayrı
toplayabiliyorduk. Tamam mı? Önce
dağıtıp sonra işlem yapıyorduk. Ya da
önce dağıtıp sonra çıkartma yapıyorduk.
Peki 9. soruya bakalım. Bir paralel
kenarım var. Muazzam. Bu paralel kenarın
çevresini
çarpmanın toplama üzerine dağılma
özelliğini kullanarak bulunuz dedi. Bak
senin çözümünü şu an kısıtladı. Normalde
işte burası 3/5, burası da 3/5 9 4 94
yazıp tek toplayabilirsin. Öyle de sonuç
çıkar. Ya öyle yaparsan öğretmenim de
böyle yapabilir. Tamam mı? Seni
kısıtlamışım.
Dağılma özelliği kullanarak bul demişim.
O zaman ne yapıyorsun? Kalemi eline
alıyor. Ç yazıp başlıyorsun. Çevre
eşittir. Paralelkenar ya da dikdörtgende
çevreyi nasıl buluyorduk? 2 tane kısa
artı uzun diyorduk. Yani 9/4 + 3/5.
Şimdi içeride bir toplama işlemi var.
Ben bunu 2 ile çarpacağım. Çünkü 2 kısa
2 uzun var ya. Haliyle burada dağılmayı
zaten kullanabilirim. Kullanıyorum.
Birinciyi birinci ile çarpıyoruz gibi
düşün. 2 x 9 18 payda 4 + Hatta duru
şimdi yazılıda mesela yazarken şöyle
yaz. 2 x 9/4
+ 2 x 3/5. Tamam mı? Bunu gösterelim.
Ondan sonra işlemleri yaparsın. E burada
sadeleştirme de varmış ya. 9/2 diyelim
buraya.
Yukarıda 2 x 3 6/5. Bundan sonra da
payda eşitlemeyle olayı
noktalayabiliriz.
5 x 9 45 + 2 x 6 12 paydamız da 10. Ne
geldi bana buradan? 57/10.
Daha da sadeleşmez. Çevresini buldum.
Hemi de dağılmayı kullandım. Tamam mı?
Haydi şimdi çok çok önemli bir yere
geçelim. Yani matematikte sembolik dil.
Şimdi esas sınavda da bence gelme
ihtimali çok kuvvetli olan bölümdeyiz.
Bir soru banko bence. Şimdi gençler
aslında bu mevzu mantık konusu. Geçen
yılın mantık eee geçen yılın değil geçen
yıl zaten arif modeldi. Ondan da önceki
yıl yani eski müfredatta 9. sınıf zaten
mantık konusuyla başlıyordu. Biz bunları
işte mantık bağlaçları var ya uzun uzun
tek anlatıyorduk. Her birini bir derse
anlatıyorduk ama şimdi tablo verip
geçiyor yeni mavi model. Dolayısıyla
eğer biraz daha detayına, derinine
ineceğim diyorsan eski müfredattaki
mantık videosunu da izlemeni tavsiye
ederim. Hatta mantık bağlaçları diye
yazıp da aratıp bulursan e oradan da
izleyebilirsin. Şöyle aslında mevzu çok
çok derin değil.
Gerçek sayılarda işlem özelliklerini
ifade eden önermeler
sembolik dil kullanılarak ifade
edilebilir. Yani aslında yine mevzu şu
translate Türkçesini verecek. Biz
buradaki sembolleri kullanarak
matematikçeye çevireceğiz.
Matematikte sembolik dilin kullanılması
matematiksel ifadelerin
standartlaştırılmasına ve
genelleştirilmesine olanak sağlar. Yani
diyor ki Amerikan'daki John bir tane
matematik formülü buldu ya da
matematiksel bir cümle kuracak. Onu
şimdi kendi diliyle yazarsa sen Ahmet,
sen Ayşe. Bunu anlayabilecek misiniz? Ha
İngilizce olmayabilir. Hadi Amerika'daki
John'u anlayabilirsin belki de. Ne
bileyim çok Hindistan'dan adam buldu.
Adam Hindistan'dan kendi diliyle yazdı.
Artık neyce konuşuyorlar şu an hiçbir
genel kültür seviyemi de buradan anlamış
oldunuz ama öyle bir şey yaptığında sen
bunu anlayamazsın kendi diliyle yazarsa
işte o yüzden matematiksel semboller
var. Şimdi burada birkaç örnek de
yapacağım zaten.
Bir niceleyicilerimiz var. Bir de mantık
bağlaçlarımız var. Niceleyiciler şu
mesela bazı kelimesini ya da en az bir
kelimesini biz şu sembolle ters e
harfiyle gösteriyoruz.
Ne demek? Mesela bazı doğal sayılar
çifttir, bazı doğal sayılar tektir. Bazı
doğal sayılar asaldır. Bazı rakamlar
asaldır demek gibi. İşte bunu söylerken
şu arkadaşla translate yapacağız.
Ya da söylediğimiz her bir değer için
geçerliyse de ters a harfi kullanacağız.
Biliyorsun matematikçiler tembel olduğu
için adam yeni bir sembol bulmaya
kasmamış kendini. Kafayı zorlamamış.
Ulan ne yapsak? A'la başlıyor alfabe.
Hadi tersten yazalım geçelim. Mevzu bu
kadar basit. Tamam mı? Sen de matematiğe
böyle basit bak. Şimdi her kelimesini de
böyle yapacağız. Yani her sayı için
geçerli. Mesela her doğal sayı için
geçerli derken o ters A'yı yazıyoruz. Bu
Osümen'in şeyi mi lan yoksa? An Osümen
matematiksel sembolle gol sevinci
yapıyor olabilir mi? Şöyle şöyle bir
şeyler yapıyor. Şuralar çizgi. Bunu bir
araştıralım. Bir bunu bence sormamız
lazım. Şimdi öyle çıksa ya. Ben
niceleyici kullanıyordum ya gol
sevincini filan diye.
Mantık bağlaçları burada şimdi V dememiz
gerekirken yine ters V harfini
kullanıyoruz. veya için şunu normal V
harfi ya da demek için kasmamış adam
yine V harfinin altına çizgi çekmiş
geçmiş eee ise de tek taraflı ok ancak
ve ancakta da çift taraflı ok
kullanıyoruz. Eee bunlarla ilgili bence
özellikle şu tarafta karşınıza çok fazla
derinlemesine bir soru çıkacağını
zannetmiyorum. Çünkü dediğim gibi yeni
marif modelde buraları derinlemesine
anlatamıyoruz. Kısıtlı müfredat da bu
kadar.
Şimdi bir bilgi verip hemen örneklere
geçiyorum. İki veya daha fazla önermeyi
birlikte ifade edebilmek için niceleyici
ve bağlaçlardan faydalanılır.
Yani şöyle eee atıyorum 2 sayısı
doğal sayıdır ve asal sayıdır değil mi?
İşte ben bu Türkçeyi matematikçeye
çevirirken şu sembolden faydalanacağım.
İkisi de aynı anda sağlanıyor ya. Hem
doğal sayı hem de asal sayı. E
dolayısıyla o v bağlacını kullanacağım.
Şimdi örnekle daha iyi anlaşılacak. Gel
10. sorumuza bakalım. Sözel vermişiz.
Türkçeden matematikçeye çevireceğiz.
Tamam. Sembolik olarak ifade edeceğiz.
Birincisi ne diyor? Bak. En az bir x
doğal sayısı için yani diyor ki en az
bir tane x var. Birazdan söyleyeceğime
uygun olan. Türkçe meali bu. Tamam mı?
Hani Türkçeden Türkçeye çeviri de
yapayım. 15/x ifadesi bir tam sayıdır.
İşte mesela nedir? x 1 olabilir, 3
olabilir, 5 olabilir ama mesela 2 olmaz.
İşte bu yüzden her x için diyemiyoruz
ama en az bir tane x sayısı bu olayı tam
sayı yapıyor. 15/ x'i tam sayı
yapabiliyormuş. Şimdi bunu matematikçeye
çevirelim. Sadece matematik sembolleri
kullanacağız ve bu yazdığımızı
Amerikan'daki John da baktığında aynı
şeyi anlayacak. Yazalım. Şimdi en azı
söylememiz lazım. Dolayısıyla şöyle
başlıyorum. En az 1 x elemanıdır doğal
sayı için. Tamam mı? En az 1x elemanıdır
doğal sayı. Çünkü şu cümle direkt bize
bunu veriyor. En az 1x doğal sayı
olacakmış.
15/
x elemanıdır. Ne istiyordu? Tam sayı
diyordu.
Z tam sayıdır. Tamam. Hatta şu araya
için diye de ufaktan bir Türkçeyi de
katalım. Bahaneyle Amerika'daki John da
Türkçeyi öğrensin. Tamam mı? Bak tekrar
edelim. En az 1x elemanıdır doğal sayı
için 15/x ifadesi elemanıdır. Tam sayı.
Yani 15/x tam sayı çıkar.
dedik. İkinciye geçiyorum. 0dan farklı
her a gerçek sayısı için a ile b
sayısının toplamının 1 olmasını sağlayan
en az bir b gerçek sayısı vardır. Şimdi
bak herle başlıyoruz. Tamam mı? Her a
değil mi? A'dan bahsediyor çünkü. Ve ne
diyor? gerçek sayı diyor. Sayı kümesini
mutlaka belirtmelisin. Yani mesela az
önce x yazdık. Bu x nereye bağlı? Nereye
bağlı olduğunu söyleyeceksin. Doğal
sayı. Şimdi sen ne yaptın? A yazdın. Bu
A'nın nereye bağlı olduğunu bana
söyleyeceğim. Nereye? Gerçek sayıya. O
zaman her A elemanıdır. Reel sayı.
Gerçek sayılar. Ve ve şöyle V diye de
yazabiliriz. Ya da normal kelimeyile de
V yazabilirsin. Ve A eşit değildir 0.
Çünkü 0dan farklı demişiz. Tamam mı?
Bunu yazdım. Bak anlayabiliyor muyuz?
Adım adım yavaş yavaş gidelim. Her A
elemanıdır gerçek sayı. Yani her gerçek
sayı için demek bu. Ve bu sayılar 0'dan
farklı olacak. Yani a 0'dan farklı
olacak. Yani 0'dan farklı her gerçek
sayı için. Şimdi ne yapacağız? A ile
B'nin toplamını eşittir 1 diyeceğiz.
Tamam. Şimdi devam ediyorum. O zaman ne
diyelim? İçin diyelim. Tamam mı?
Ne diyor? A ile B'nin toplamı
A + B = 1 ise ise buraya hatta
matematiksel sembolü de çakabilirsin.
İse sembolünü ne diyeceğiz? En az bir b
gerçek sayısı vardır diyor. O zaman en
az bir tane B vardır. R elemanı olan
yani gerçek sayıya ait olan en az bir
tane B vardır diyeceğiz. Tekrar
ediyorum. Her A gerçek sayısı için ama A
0'dan farklı olacak. A + B 1 ise madem
böyle bir şey oluşuyor o zaman en az bir
tane B vardır reel sayılarda diyoruz.
Tamam mı? Mevzu bu.
Şimdi matematikçeden Türkçeye çevirelim.
Burada bu arada geçen yılki videomuzu da
izlemeni tavsiye ederim. Orada farklı
örneklerle de Türkçe matematikçe
translate yapmıştık. O da bir ek sana
kaynak soru çözümü olsun. Şimdi sembolik
olarak ifade edilen önermeleri sözel
olarak yazacağız. Hemen bakalım. Bak
herle başlamış. Nerede elemanımız?
Kümesi neresi bunun? R yani reel sayı.
Gerçek sayılar. diyor ki x² >= 0. Tamam.
O zaman bunu hemen Türkçeye çevirelim.
Ne yazacağız? Her gerçek
sayı için ya da direkt şöyle diyelim.
Her gerçek sayının karesi direkt
söyleyelim karesi 0
veya 0'dan büyüktür.
Tamam. Türkçemi de gördünüz değil mi?
0dan büyüktür. Onu ben doktorca yazısı
bu. Tamam. Doktorca ben her hafta sonu
bir saat çalışırım doktorca yazmaya.
Şimdi geldim diğerine. Burada en azla
başlıyoruz ve 5x + 4 = 0 diyeceğiz. Ne
diyor? En az bir tane x elemanıdır doğal
sayı için 5x + 4 = 0'dır demiş. O zaman
ne diyeceğim? Bazı
doğal sayıların tamam mı? Bazı doğal
sayıların
5 katının 4 fazlası
0a eşittir.
Tamam. Mevzu bu. Ne yaptım? Türkçeye
çevirmiş oldum. Bu bir önerme. Bu arada
şimdi şunu diyebilirsin. Hocam bu doğru
mu? Eee böyle bir doğal sayı var mı? Yok
aslında. Böyle bir doğal sayı yok.
Yanlış bir önerme. Bu bizim derdimiz mi
peki? Bu benim sorudum mu? Yanlışsa
yanlış. yanlış olarak kalsın. Ben benim
derdim translate. Tamam mı? İçerik
önemli değil. Dolayısıyla mevzuyu burada
noktalıyorum. 8. ders bitti. Ne
yapıyoruz? 9. derste yine devam edeceğiz
konumuza. Gerçek sayıların işlem
özelliklerine devam edeceğiz. Çok çok
önemli yerlere de değineceğiz. 9. ders
daha böyle içerik olarak seni çarpan
vuran bir yapı da olabilir. Haberin
olsun. E önden hazırlık da yapabilirsin.
Bu arada yine Mor Tosuncukta devam
ediyoruz. Dediğim gibi incelemek
isterseniz, edinmek isterseniz açıklama
kısmında linklerini bulabilirsiniz
sevgili 9. sınıflar hadi bakalım.
Hepinizi seviyorum. İnşallah yazılıya
kadar çok iyi çalışacaksın ve ilk yazılı
şöyle liseyle tanışma. Tamam mı? İlk
sınavda şöyle güzel bir notla
başlayalım. Güzel başlayalım, güzel
devam edelim. Tamam. İnşallah bu yılı da
yüksek bir not ortalamasıyla
bitireceğiz. Çünkü yeni modeldesin, yeni
maarif modeldesin. Yeni bir sınav
sistemi ile karşılaşacağız. Bu yazılı
puanları, yazılı notların çok kritik bir
öneme sahip olabilir. Yani olmasa bile
bu konulara hazırlıklı olmamız lazım
zaten ama olacaktır. Çünkü lisede şu
anda da çok büyük bir öneme sahip okul
notları. Dolayısıyla sen de ne olur ne
olmaz çat diye mesela çok önemli daha da
önemli bir hale gelebilir bu yazılı
notlarımız. O yüzden biz hani derler ya
eşeği sağlam kaza bağlayacaksın diye biz
de yazılıları 100'e bağlayalım. Orada da
kalsın. Tamam. Haydi o zaman sevgili 9.
sınıflar bir sonraki derste yeniden
görüşünceye dek kendinize çok iyi bakın
ve matematikle kalın. Hoşça kalın.
he